Black History Month is a time to
celebrate Black Culture but it's also an
opportunity to have some tough
conversations our Candice Charles breaks
down the stigma around mental health in
the black community offering resources
and some promising news
after getting rejected
we just closed up Gina Hill has been
dealing with mental health alone for 30
plus years her daughter started therapy
at age 13 after a traumatic incident
while she suffered in silence until he
lost her sister during the pandemic I
got into the end of myself but her first
stop wasn't a doctor's office it was
church people would want to pray and I
would pray but I still was I was still
battling for many blacks church is often
the first and only stop 98 of
psychiatrists are white so the church
was and still is perceived as the only
place to lay down your burdens with
someone who looks like you Tyler Perry
unlv's African-American studies
assistant professor says the lack of
access in mental health professionals is
just a part of the problem in the late
18th century when white Physicians
attempted to diagnose black slaves there
was an assumption that black people felt
less pain black Americans are were
effectively disenfranchised from any
discussion about mental health leading
to a foundation of suffering and silence
and I think for African Americans the
mentality has been is that life has been
rough being black and American so you do
what you have to do to survive you don't
have time to complain you don't have
time to stop the stigma that those who
seek help from mental health are weak
runs deep in fact one study showed that
63 percent of black people believe that
a mental health condition is a sign of
personal weakness Dr Sheldon Jacobs
would name me the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Southern Nevada tells me
breaking the stigma will help save lives
getting through some of course our Norms
is is is huge because they are merriers
the good news recent Studies have shown
that college age black people are
seeking mental help at a higher rate the
hope is that they will be more likely to
care for their children's mental health
for Hill helping her child early made
all the difference she actually is just
getting her master's degree in mental
health counseling
that was Candace Charles there with that
story now we have a full list of
resources including a list of black
mental health professionals and the
pastors who work alongside them on our
website you're just going to go to
8newsnow.com